I really see the future of my channel on
Pearl daily not on the pregame I think
I'm going to do an odd one here or there
but I I decided this for two reasons
number one I'm just tired I feel like
I've learned what I needed to learn from
interviewing these chicks and I don't
know something like changed over time
when I was smaller there was a little
bit more of like a genuine and
conversation people used to have and
that was kind of why I loved it I loved
having these like open honest
conversations where we could go into
like topics that were kind of taboo I
really liked that the bigger I got the
more people just kind of want to come on
for clout get their 10 seconds of Fame